the intelligence officer was asked to
vacate the u.s embassy and leave the
country it's a big step for germany
which is increasingly fed up with
washington's failure to cooperate with
its probe into nsa spying
berlin has struck a new tone on the
matter with ministers in chancellor
merkel's government using words like
stupidity and ridiculous
merkel herself not usually one for
strong statements was quite clear
the way i see it if you consider this
with a healthy dose of common sense it's
a waste of energy to spy on one's allies
i think that the important thing is to
create trust between allies especially
in these confusing times
there's been continued silence from the
u.s
that's anchored germany the most
especially amid allegations of double
agents spying for washington politicians
from all sides are supporting the
government's decision to expel the u.s
intelligence official
i think this is the correct reaction
considering that we've been asking the
americans many questions for more than a
year now and haven't got any answers
the german government means to
re-establish trust
then it must ensure at the highest
levels
that the us's silence in response to
these allegations
comes to an end
berlin's patience with the u.s is
wearing thin despite close ties between
the nations it appears that restoring
diplomatic trust is still a long way off
you